i can only imagine what it
is you're going through
anytime you're going to cast a role as
big as spider-man there's a
huge search involved and seraphin and
her team looked at 7
500 tapes it was crazy it was a pretty
daunting process i went through a phase
of just doing self tapes after self
tapes after self tapes i guess when you
can do what i can do maybe
maybe you have a responsibility to do
some good with then we met about
200 boys and there were so many of them
that were so good
but tom was different than everyone else
there was just something about tom
holland's performance that was just so
energetic and real and grounded and full
of attitude
it was all these screen tests and i got
to meet tom while he was
in the final run in there guys i'm going
to jump the gun uh
yeah i'm ready i'm ready okay yeah i
love adventure
yeah tom we got even luckier because we
found a kid who not only is a great
actor but he also can do a standing back
flip just for fun for a young man
walking into a room
with robert downey and into a room with
chris evans
that's got to be terrifying as an actor
like you're walking in with probably
your childhood idols
do i need to do that i know we're on
different teams i just don't want to be
disrespectful to you
surrender whoa that thing is not a big
laws of physics
and um obviously he got the gig what are
you what are you what are you doing here
it's about time we met
you been getting my emails right about
the grand the september foundation all
right
yeah remember when you applied seriously
kid where are you from queens
maybe it's time you went back to queens
a little help thank you
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man marvel
phase 4 video with avengers easter eggs
iron man marvel phase 4 easter eggs so
we'll break it all down
it's funny watching tom holland's
original audition there for captain
america civil war in the avengers movies
it gives you a really good sense for his
evolving relationship with those
characters with captain america in
iron man so i'll talk about them during
marvel phase 4 and some of the easter
eggs heading into spider-man 3
as well as avengers 5 and the other
future tom holland mcu movies
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing giveaways for copies of the
marvel avengers game all you have to do
to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know what
kind of iron man easter eggs you want
them to include in spider-man 3. all the
improv they did all the back flips that
he did on the spot the russos actually
told him before that audition to go
ahead and do the backflips the other
funny thing about his audition here that
you may not know is that is actually
chris hemsworth that put in a good word
for him so he actually worked with chris
hemsworth on a movie before this
happened
so they were already buds he knew that
tom holland was going up for spider-man
so he tried to put in a good word with
executive producers with kevin feige
with the disney ceo
but it is fun to watch his relationship
with those characters with iron man and
captain america evolve through avengers
end game and now spider-man far from
home
even though captain america is an old
man living in retirement right now
spider-man is still a huge cap fan boy
and they give you a pretty good idea for
how his relationship with the iron man
character has evolved
since his death still an iron man fanboy
but the whole plot of far from home as
the producers say was intended to be him
learning the truth of fake nick fury's
words heavy is the head that wears the
crown
spider boy becoming spider-man making
his own suits
i know everyone is really excited to see
spider-man be more like comic book
spider-man and do more things
on his own it seems like that's going to
be happening during spider-man 3 taking
him back to spider-man basics
but getting into more iron man
spider-man marvel phase 4 easter egg
spider-man 3 avengers 5
a lot of you been asking what's going to
happen with the stark tech glasses edith
in the orbital weapons platform
in all the stark tech that he has access
to around the world
because even though pepper is still
technically ceo handling the day-to-day
running of stark industries
she's mostly being a mom to morgan stark
raising her till she winds up turning
into the katherine langford version of
the character that we saw during that
avengers endgame alternate ending scene
she also said that she'd love to come
back for those either hoping for some
young
avengers deep cuts when they get into
big time travel story lines
gwyneth paltrow kind of said that she's
semi-retired from marvel movies pending
robert downey jr asking her to come back
if he comes back to cameo she said that
she would always come back to be pepper
to iron man's tony stark so it sounds
like
we won't see any pepper unless iron man
comes back
but spider-man still has to eat his
glasses at the end of spider-man far
from home he did not give those back
in the glasses give spider-man way more
than just the weapons platform
we already know that the ai is a full
new version of friday like the newest
version of jarvis because jarvis became
vision during avengers age of ultron
then iron man built friday to replace
him and now edith is replacing friday
i'm assuming that suit lady the karen ai
that was inside the classic stark tech
suit isn't around anymore because he
kind of destroyed that suit and built
the new one
but you have to imagine that anything
that friday could do for iron man give
him access to any stark tech around the
world
as well as hack other tech the new edith
glasses can also do that for spider-man
and even before he got edith his regular
stark tech suit the classic one
before the upgrade was able to hack the
new york city passport office to get him
through the line faster when he was
running around town getting ready for
the class trip
edith is way more powerful than what he
had in that old stark tech suit
he's going to need all the advantages
that he can get to keep him one step
ahead of the law
in the sinister six villains that are
going to be chasing him around during
spider-man 3 at least until he clears
his name
i know everyone's still holding out for
daredevil hope he needs a lawyer to help
him
there's also she-hulk technically she's
a lawyer in the mcu we know she's going
to get a disney plus series
but no idea when they're going to
introduce that character as of this fall
marvel is also free to use the daredevil
character again but right now that's
just speculation that daredevil is going
to show up during an mcu movie
right now the other avengers who are
still alive would also be able to help
him on the dl
war machine is one of the few who are
still technically government employees
because he's still active military so he
does have to answer to thunderbolt ross
on the world security council
but even during avengers infinity war he
effectively muted all notifications from
thunderbolt ross in order to help
captain
america secret avengers when they showed
up with vision so regardless of who they
have to answer to
any of the avengers are fair game to do
spider-man a solid during spider-man 3.
but one of the other really cool iron
man things that the avengers movies
never got into
that much was the idea that because of
the way stark tech has engineered all
the software all the hardware
tony stark has backdoor access the
jarvis or friday or now edith
can instantly hack so if a criminal or a
villain somewhere around the world
stole a bunch of stark tech weaponry
spider-man's new edith ai
can actually hack that remotely and take
it over that also includes
all of iron man's armory now i don't
expect him to start wearing any kind of
iron man suits because he had the iron
spider suit he still has that back at
aunt may's house
but the whole idea of spider-man 3 is
that he can't go home so i think the
idea is that he won't be able to get
that suit he'll have the one that he
just upgraded
that'll probably get destroyed too
because he always gets a new suit every
single movie
but effectively spider-man now has
control of
all stark tech of any kind all over the
world
including that weapon's platform it's
just all the focus was on the weapons
platform during far from home
but i think part of the idea in starting
spider-man 3 where they do with the
character with him on the run
is to make him feel like he's isolated
from everyone else his old friends the
other avengers
can't go home can't go hide out at the
avengers base because it was destroyed
the real key i think during spider-man 3
is again
nick fury showing up the real nick fury
this time
he helped him during far from home but
technically it was by proxy through fake
nick fury aka the scrolls talos and his
wife
they weren't even supposed to be there
for anything more than being glorified
couriers that's the way that talos
explains it during that apologetic phone
call to nick fury in the post-credits
scene
we gave the kid the glasses like you
asked to he was just supposed to give
him the edith glasses as part of iron
man's last will and testament and that
was
it but then all the mysterio stuff with
the elementals blew up and then everyone
started asking for the avengers to rush
in
and help and he had no idea where the
avengers were because his talos and real
nick fury didn't tell him what was going
on with the avengers after end game
so like he said we really need you to
come back so it's safe to say that nick
fury comes back for at least a small
cameo to help clean up the mess that
spider-man and mysterio
created but for those of you wanting
more classic comic book spider-man him
doing things on his own making his own
tech his own suits when you think about
the events of the last two films in his
arc they've slowly been stripping away
all of the iron man tech that's built
into his suits so during spider-man 3
it's pretty easy prediction to make
that'll have to rely on his own
abilities more his own instincts talking
about spidey sense or the spidey tingle
whatever they want to call it in the mcu
more of him macgyvering himself out of
situations while he's fighting new
sinister six villains
they kind of did that with the iron man
character during iron man 3. they
basically took him out of the suit and
he had to macgyver his way through that
mandarin
situation even though it was the fake
mandarin the real mandarin will show up
during the shane chi movie i've already
done a teaser video for that because we
got some behind the scenes footage
i'll link it at the end of this because
there are some funny moments with the
trevor version of the mandarin
but thematically i think we can all
agree that craven is probably the top
pick
for the villain that you're going to
introduce during spider-man 3 taking
things back to basics
taking them back to their more
animalistic state hunting spider-man
like an animal let me know in the
comments though going forward in the
spider-man movies in the marvel
cinematic universe
what kind of iron man easter eggs do you
want to see them include in the stories
as spider-man continues to evolve as a
character and get older
recently there was a bunch of news about
the title for spider-man 3 possibly
leaking out you can click here to learn
all about that
and you can click here for that marvel
shang chi movie teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!